die debatte um die erneute
veröffentlichung dieses buches geführt
wird
herbert winter ist präsident des
schweizerischen israelitischen
gemeindebundes des dachverbandes der
juden in der schweiz
herr winter wie kommen diese erneute
publikation von hitlers mein kampf bei
jüdinnen und juden in der schweiz sehr
unterschiedlich bevor ich darauf antwort
da möchte ich vielleicht auch sagen der
film hat bisher erschüttert und zwar
nicht so sehr das buch sondern die
aussagen die in diesem film gezeigt
werden von hitler
die sind die gehen mir sehr tief runter
und berühren mich sehr und ich habe von
verschiedenen anderen leuten in unsere
gemeinschaft gehört haben sie sehr
berührt dass das buch nur raus kommt in
dieser form führt zu verschiedenen
reaktionen wie sie sich vorstellen
können
die einen finden das sinnvoll im sinn
von aufklärung erziehung die anderen vor
allem jene die den zweiten weltkrieg
persönlich erlebt haben und an falls den
holocaust überlebt haben für die ss
beinahe unerträglich das buch rauskommt
gefühlsebene und es geht so die
sachliche gegangen
dies führe ich auch bei mir bei mir rein
persönlich gefühlsmäßig habe ich größte
probleme mit dem buch muss ich sagen
also ich sagen dass immerhin fehlen oder
ist plötzlich hitler wieder dass sie
sprechen ja nicht die experten und sie
sprechen ja die ausschnitte und genau
ich nur plötzlich wieder aufgenommen
und dass dieses buch in der buchhandlung
jetzt erscheint wo man reingeht und da
sieht man mein kampf ist für mich und
sicher viel in unsere gemeinschaft
schwierig zu ertragen und da muss ich
den kopf an falls ansprechen bei mir und
als präsident des dachverbands muss ich
eine eher politische sachliche nicht
emotional bezogene position einnehmen
und sehen natürlich auch die hoffentlich
positiven seiten die das buch auslöst
sie sprechen jetzt von der kritischen
edition ist wird also nicht auch hitlers
mein kampf das buch sozusagen neu
aufgelegt sondern es liegt
vom institut für zeitgeschichte von
münchen ein zweibändiges werk vor das
also beinahe doppelt so umfangreich ist
wie das original
sie sagen diese edition die kritische
mit vielen anmerkungen die soll
erscheinen oder die sollte eben auch
nicht erscheinen ich sage ich sie soll
erscheinen sie werde erscheinen sie ist
dass sie ist da wie sie ist in der
schweiz gab ich noch nicht erhältlich
doch doch endlich endlich sie darauf
sage 4000 bis vor wenigen tagen war sie
nicht aber egal
sie wird erscheinen und sie wird ihren
platz einnehmen
die frage ist eher was was bringt sie
und da wie gesagt ich habe vorher nur
von dieser kritischen ausgabe gesprochen
nicht vom original das wird nämlich
jetzt einmal an nimmt sie nicht wieder
schweizer scheinen weil damit wird
natürlich direkt die rassismusstrafnorm
verletzt
diese ausgabe wird im buchhandel
erscheinen und von dieser war er hoffe
ich zumindest dass sie im rahmen der
erziehung präventionsarbeit ihren nutzen
bringt für lehrer für historiker also
freier bin ich nicht ganz grundsätzlich
gegen die ausgabe dieses buches
sie sprechen jetzt auch als jurist das
sind sie von haus aus lich es gibt
typische stimmen auch in der schweiz die
sagen nein
aus rücksicht auf die opfer des
holocaust hätte auch diese kommentierte
ausgabe nicht erscheinen sollen ich habe
wirklich volles verständnis für diese
haltung und ich kenne selber einige
überlebende des holocaust die familie
meiner frau hat nicht den holocaust
überlebt aber waren verfolgte vom ns
regime und von daher habe ich viel
verständnis und respekt vor dieser
haltung und kann diese gefühle auch
mitteilen
und da muss ich sagen ich habe
einerseits eine gefühls haltung und
andererseits eine politische haltung von
der ich sage ich hoffe dass wenn
vernünftig verwendet wird dieses buch
auch seine nutzen haben
also wir können da man blick reinwerfen
das sind zwei bände
im ersten run zum beispiel gibt es da
den begriff der rassenschande kommt hier
eben im originaltext vor wird dann
sozusagen erläutert dann mit anmerkungen
also auf der einen seite steht der
originaltext dann auf der anderen seite
die anmerkungen da wird dann genau
erläutert woher die begriffe kommen wie
das historisch gewachsen ist lässt sich
hitler dekonstruieren
wie gesagt ich habe die kommentierung
nicht gelesen ich denke ich hoffe er
erwarte eigentlich dass diese so gut
geschrieben ist dass sie wirklich täter
entlarvt und seine kriminelle erhaltung
und ideologie völlig entlarvt das ist
eigentlich meine hoffnung oder mein
anspruch an dieses buch und wenn sie
nicht sagen
die ein verbot eines buches macht ein
buch schon mal per sehr interessant
macht mein kampf viel mehr zu einem
fetisch als wenn man sagt da ist es
absolut ja dumm bin ich ja nicht per se
gegen die ausgabe dieses buches und das
verbot bringt ohnehin wenig würde nichts
bringen oder sehr wenig weil das buch
ist erhältlich nicht in buchform
vielleicht europa aber auf internet
finden sie den text ins ausgaben also
wer wirklich den text lesen will der hat
in eine originalausgabe die stadt dann
so aus mit konterfei unterschrift zwölf
millionen mal gescheite großes geschäft
gewesen für hitler an sie die auch schon
in händen gehabt ich habe sie vor jahren
einmal den händen gehabt ja und wie
gesagt es immer wenn ich sie vor mir
habe läuft zwar ziemlich kalt über den
rücken
haben sie ist
gelesen nein ich habe ich echt
schwierigkeiten das buch zu lesen und
werde das auch jetzt nicht lesen
ich möchte diesem buch nicht ja die
bedeutung zumessen
die man die jetzt vielleicht auch mit
diesen neuen ausgabe wieder herauskommt
am liebsten hätte ich das dieses buch im
giftschrank versorgt wird und weg die
zeit die zeitung die zeit sagt das
schaut aus wie eine bibelausgabe es ist
etwas bewiesen sehr gleichen zeit auch
es viel erfüllt diesen aufklärerischen
anspruch
es gibt gegenstimmen sie haben das jetzt
auch sehr ambivalent eingeordnet jetzt
mal weg von diesen edition mich
interessiert einfach wenn dieses buch
jetzt wieder da ist
ist das heute noch gefährlich wie
schätzen sie das ein
also ich glaube für einen aufgeklärten
modernen menschen ist das buch nicht
gefährlich dass jene die einem diesem
oder ähnlichen auch wenig extrem
gedankengut anhängen allenfalls dann nur
den text lesen und nicht die die
erläuterungen dazu das kann zu einer
natürlich eine gewisse gefahr bringen
und das möchte ich nicht von der hand
weisen
auf der anderen seite ist es aus
jüdischer sicht sicher so dass das
erscheinen dieser form sehr viel besser
ist als einfach eine originalausgabe
also zu verschiedenen stimmen zu dieser
ausgabe was philosophen insbesondere
dazu meinen gibt's jetzt aktuell bei uns
einen online artikel zu lesen
aber ist es nicht besser eigentlich wenn
wir das eingeordnet haben wenn wir die
quellen offengelegt haben
ja das denke ich auch also weil es ja im
internet erhältlich ist ist es ja nicht
so dass es völlig von der welt weg ist
und von daher wenn schon etwas rauskommt
dass es in dieser form rauskommt ist
sinnvoll und hat ich wiederhole mich
hoffentlich die wirkung die eigentlich
die
das institut damit haben will dass es im
rahmen der erziehung präventionsarbeit
auch verwende sinnvoll verwendet wird
was genau ist gefährlich da dran
also wenn ich wie gesagt ich habe es
jetzt natürlich ohnehin nicht gelesen
aber aus dem film heraus gewisse
statements leute die diesem gedankengut
anhängen fühlen sich natürlich bestätigt
und das ist gefährlich was auch
gefährlich oder problematisch zumindest
ist ist dass man dem buch und der
ideologie dahinter steckt darin nicht
steckt sondern versinnbildlicht ist eine
bedeutung zumisst die sieht man ja
eigentlich nicht mehr geben will
und so kann das ganze thema wieder sehr
aktuell gut werden interessant werden
und das finde ich schon glaube ich
nichts problem damit das tut diese
aufgabe aber ich bin etwas erstaunt dass
sie ich kann es einerseits bestehen aber
was sie sagen sich ich habe das gar
nicht gelesen
hängt das zusammen die frage habe ich
mir überlegt womit hängt das zusammen
ich habe sicher ausschnittweise davon
gelesen ich habe über das buch vieles
gelesen in den jahren seit ich erwachsen
bin natürlich ich kenne die theorien die
darin sind ich hatte nie dann hatten wir
das verlangen
das buch zu lesen kann es nicht mehr
erklären
in vielen diskutieren die experten
experten ob der holocaust die
vernichtung der juden in diesem buch 19
25 19 26 erschienen bereits festgelegt
ist wie beurteilen sie diese diskussion
in welche richtung gehen sie da ich habe
gesagt ich hab's nicht gelesen ich kann
nur wiedergeben was in diesem film
gesagt wurde der ein experte sagt die
aussage wird nicht gemacht das ist zum
zur endlösung kommen sollte auf der
anderen seite werden aussagen gemacht
die ganz klar sagen man das gemäss dem
experten dass
juden ein problem sind mann soll zum
beispiel in 15.000 juden töten also von
tötung von juden ist thema eines ist
thema in diesem buch und das man sich
wenn man über die ganze rassentheorie
die den deutschen staat schadet und im
deutschen volk startet dann einfach
gedanklich weiter knüpft dann zumindest
im nachhinein kann man sehen dass das
die grundlage war für den holocaust also
ich hab gelesen hier ein zitat hier
schreckt er vor nichts zurück und wird
in seiner gemeinheit so riesengroß dass
sich niemand zu wundern braucht wenn in
unserem folge die personifikation des
teufels als sinnbild alles bösen die
leibhaftige gestalt des juden arm nimmt
ja das ist für mich eigentlich ein
hinweis dem man so heute zumindest so
verstehen muss als damit hatte
eigentlich indirekt stillschweigen zu
hause gebracht was sein ziel war er hat
aber nicht offenbar gemäss dem experten
der im film auftritt nicht ausdrücklich
von einer lösung gesprochen aber wenn
man diesen satz sieht und ob man noch
viele andere ähnliche statements die im
buch vorkommen dann setzt es fast keinen
anderen schluss zu als sagt er
die juden müssten von der erdoberfläche
verschwinden
jesus von nazareth war ein jude in der
folge müssten eigentlich auch die
christen von der erdoberfläche
verschwinden
eine interessante feststellung aber eben
nach jesus christus sind die christen
christen geworden
also von daher bin ich glaube so viel
ich weiß und gelesen habe hat natürlich
hitler auch mit den christen als
christliche religion und christliche
religionsgemeinschaft probleme gehabt
das wandern für ihn halt doch nicht mehr
juden
ja
jetzt liegt das werk in dieser
kritischen edition vor wie sollen wir
denn jetzt damit umgehen gehört denn
jetzt dieser stoff zum beispiel gehört
der mein kampf aus stoff in der schweiz
in die schulen nicht also der der stoff
gehört in die schulen genauso wie ganz
grundsätzlich die zeit des ns-regimes in
schulen gehört und wenn man von mein
kampf spricht dann soll man dieses buch
so verwenden um zu zeigen was diese
theorie und was diese ideologie
eigentlich ausmacht in dem sinn gehört
es in die schulen sehr sorgfältig
bearbeitet natürlich durch den lehrer
und das daran dass er hoffe ich wird das
leistbar sein
die zukunft wird es zeigen also wir
machen von unserem dachverband aus
natürlich auch präventionsarbeit wir
bringen alle zwei jahre lehrergruppen
nach auschwitz um ihm zu zeigen was
letzten endes das wie soll ich sagen
das finale von diesem berg war versuchen
auf anderen ebenen zu zeigen was diese
rassenideologie auslöste
von daher hoffe ich kann nur die
hoffnung aussprechen dass das gelingen
wird die kritische edition also diese
beiden bände 4000 exemplare sind weg
15.000 vorbestellungen werden sie es
noch lesen wenn ich zeit habe werde ich
sicher darin blättern und werde aber
sicher sehr viel darüber lesen um ihren
fans zu zeigen wo ich allenfalls die
besonders interessanten stellen finden
werde
wenn wir jetzt darüber gesprochen haben
dass man versucht jetzt aufklären statt
dahinter zu gehen sie aber doch auch
zustimmen da steht doch schon einiges
drin
über das was mit den juden geschehen
wird
war das deine ausrede wir haben von
nichts gewusst ich denke es war eine
ausrede man hat vielleicht auf deutsche
bevölkerung nichts
nicht vorausgesehen dass es zu einem
verkauf kommt zu einem industriellen
massenmord das hat man möglicherweise
nicht vorausgesehen
aber dass man mit den juden extrem
schlecht bis kriminell umgehen wird das
kann man darin lesen ich frage wäre dann
sagt ich hätte da all das nicht
vorausgesehen
der lügt und er hat gesehen die meisten
leute zumindestens städten haben gesehen
die nachbarn jüdischen waren nicht mehr
da auf den geschäften ist es jude kauf
hier nicht ein
also zu sagen man hat das alles nicht
vorausgesehen ist schwierig das man
nicht auschwitz vorausgesehen hat damit
das kann ich noch nachvollziehen diese
überlegung
also ich bin gespannt ob diese debatten
jetzt aufgrund eben dieser kritischen
edition der offenlegung von quellen und
die diskussion noch mal auf kommt euer
fahrt gewinnt wie ist es emotional für
die juden für die juden in der schweiz
haben sie den eindruck der
antisemitismus wird sich noch mal
verstärken durch diese edition wird
dieser diskussion
das glaube ich nicht schon am anfang
gesagt habe ich glaube leute die offen
sind tolerant sind ein offenes weltbild
haben werden sicher auch durch das lesen
dieser da dieses buches nicht zu
antisemiten werden und die anderen die
ich schon sind die werden anfangs
bestärkt in ihrer auf einer ihrer
meinung was für mich eigentlich noch ein
wichtiger aspekt ist auf den ich doch
aufmerksam machen möchte ist dass das
buch in dem sie in ein problem für uns
darstellt aus meiner sicht dass wir
juden wieder einmal als opfer
dargestellt werden
in der ganzen geschichte der juden auch
wir selbst häufig selber häufig sprechen
immer nur von holocaust holocaust als
ein identifikationsmerkmal von
identitäts merkmal von uns
und so werden wir häufiger auch gesehen
von der außenwelt und dabei wir haben
vor zehn tagen haben wir 150 jahre man
situation der juden in der schweiz
gefeiert wir möchten zeigen eigentlich
wir sind hier in der schweiz als bürger
dieses landes voll gleichberechtigt auf
augenhöhe miteinander das ist das bild
das wir eigentlich viel lieber von uns
vermitteln möchten und wenn jetzt diese
geschichte wieder aufkommt dass in der
wieder die opfer die geschlagen werden
das mit dem habe ich auch denn das
problem die ambivalenten gefühle hatten
am anfang mit diesem statement sie die
juden in der schweiz seit 150 jahren
schließen wir ganz herzlich danken
hier gibt es jetzt gleich weiter mit der
sternstunde philosophie und dem
schillernden historiker und querdenker
neil ferguson